[Musique]
me revoilà oui je le vois
en enfer une rumeur circule il se crame
quelque chose là haut un peu plus haut
l'archange Gabriel a disparu je crois
qu'il s'est rendu sur terre
bonjour bonjour bonjour madame le
fichier
c'est un officier de police humain vous
avez trouvé Gabriel c'est sûr qu'il est
pas dans la librairie il n'y a qu'à dire
rafale le traître
et son ami grincheux monsieur rempart
le démon je suppose que c'est explique
le côté un peu grincheux j'ai un
problème urgent quand il faut absolument
qu'on parle et aussi bien sûr son
assistant salut
Gabriel qu'est-ce qu'il fait ici j'en
sais rien il lui arrive quoi j'en sais
rien
pourquoi êtes-vous venu ah ma boutique
est-ce que vous savez ce que ça fait
quand vous ne savez rien du tout et que
vous êtes intimement convaincu que tout
irait beaucoup mieux si vous étiez en
compagnie d'une certaine
on va faire ça ensemble ensemble
le temps qu'on comprenne ce qui se passe
je crois que je viens de déclencher une
guerre oh ça va pas plaire à l'enfer
vous êtes un démon je vais être
tellement dans la mouise dans ce cas
autant pas faire les choses à moitié
[Musique]